what's going on guys Quentin Tarantino
one of the great directors of our
generation has his eighth film in
theaters now the hateful eight well
today we're going to decide what the
best Quentin Tarantino movie of all time
is we have an awesome panel of critics
to decide it for us let's meet him shall
we first he's an old friend of the show
open with us several times the Nerdist
critic at-large Kyle Anderson he's also
a friend of the show he is the brains
behind schmoes know and you know him
from Collider movie talk and he's a
funny stand-up comic Mark Ellis and he
is the Brawn behind schmoes know and you
know from Collider Jedi Council and
Fandango Kristian harloff so fYI we are
taking quentin tarantino's eight films
and matching them up one verse eight to
verse 7 and so on and so forth according
to their IMDB rankings and fun fact
quentin tarantino considers Kill Bill
volumes 1 & 2 one film so that's what
we're doing are you guys cool with that
doesn't matter that's what we're doing
the first one already a Sophie's Choice
on the board
number two Django Unchained against
number 7 Jackie Brown Jamie Foxx vs. Pam
Grier Robert De Niro versus Leonardo
DiCaprio
I think it's Samuel Jackson versus
Samuel Jackson is the is the big that's
what I should have said first yeah both
of those movies are great I'm gonna
actually I'm gonna go with Django just
because the scope of a film it's so much
bigger and it I'm a big westerns fan
Marc Ellis you know how I really want to
take Jackie Brown because it's one of
the best post Batman Michael Keaton
appearances that you're going to see but
I'm gonna have to go with Kyle over here
Django Unchained is Tarantino in his
wheelhouse it's a Western he knows how
to knock those out of the park and sing
DiCaprio in the scene when he actually
hurts his hand and they use that take in
the movie that's if you bleed for a
movie that's why I'm voting for you
there we go
Django Unchained moving on to the second
round Christian just for some gigs any
thoughts I would have also gone with
Django I think that he gets better
Tarantino gets better every single movie
and there's a reason why he won
the Oscar for that screenplay fellas you
know there's a big group of Jackie Brown
fans out there and they all hate you now
leave mean comments about Mark Ellis
Kyle Anderson Kristian harloff blow okay
his first major film Reservoir Dogs
against number six Kill Bill volumes 1
and 2 what a matchup this is Christian
we're gonna go down the other end and
start with you this time
oh man cuz Kill Bill is one of my fav
Alim 1 into 1 big movie it's maybe my
favorite I don't think it's his best but
it might be my favorite but Reservoir
Dogs I mean everything he did whether or
dogs at scene just just stuck in the
middle with you with Michael Madsen
talking into the ear I mean Reservoir
Dogs I hate to say ought to go dogs
that's one for dogs I'm kind of in the
same boat as Christian I think Kill Bill
is so much fun to I mean that's what
that's two movies or one movie where you
can sit and just watch four hours of a
movie and it's just you have a great
time but I do think Reservoir Dogs he
just comes right out of the gates yes
for the fences and uh you know people
walk down the street with suits and
sunglasses on because of that movie
Reservoir Dogs moving on Ellis just for
certain giggles any thoughts I'm going
reservoir doesn't matter it's already
moving on gentlemen it gets no easier
number for inglorious basterds versus
number five the hateful eight yeah Mark
Ellis start us off I'm gonna kick us off
and I'm going to take us back to World
War two I believe how because I enjoyed
the hateful way I saw it recently
haven't had a chance to revisit it as
much obviously as I haven't goriias
Basterds but what Angoras bastards did
changing history flipping it on its ear
and even if it didn't have that I think
I have to get the tiebreaker to
inglorious basterds for the opening
scene when we got to meet Christoph
Waltz when we're talking about milk with
a simple farmer and oh my god became so
much more than that one of the best
scenes of that decade yeah let's go to
Kyle and right and tough matchup it's
super tough an inglorious basterds is
probably one of my favorite if not my
favorite Tarantino movie but I'm I was
so blown away by the hateful eight
recently having watched should have only
seen at the one time I was I was taken
in by the whole experience of the
seventy mill with the intermission in
the middle and you know you get the
little program booklet I will say that I
came out of that movie liking it so much
more than I did the first time I saw
inglorious basterds I definitely came
around more on that one so I'm gonna
go with hateful eight let's go with the
newbie I'll be a whimsical dandy we call
me ladies and gentlemen we've got
ourselves a ball game Kristian harloff
the Higgs down to you the hateful eight
was in my top ten this year for the same
exact reasons what you just mentioned
that this is a movie that is so much fun
it's an experience it has all that
classic Tarantino dialogue they were
talking to her Trussell and Jennifer
Jason Leigh just knocking it out of the
park is on Sam Jackson might have one of
his best performances ever in this movie
and I had a lot of fun with it but
inglorious basterds to me is a movie
that I actually did the first time I saw
it it just blew me away because of that
opening scene and what Christoph wall
stood Tarantino changed history what if
that actually happened you know what I
mean it did happen you know that's
that's the type of energy I felt
watching and glorious bastards
inglorious bastards there you have it
inglorious basterds the final matchup of
the first round fellas your number one
film
Pulp Fiction will it get knocked off by
the number eight death Proof Kyle
Anderson are you going to pick death
proof over pulp fiction I'm not because
I'm not a crazy person Mark Ellis are
you going to pick death proof over pulp
fiction it comes with a warning while I
will pick pulp fiction I'm going to say
that it's dangerous later in this game
to get to cocky if you're Pulp Fiction
because it could be upset Pulp Fiction
is moving on but Kristian harloff quick
thoughts on death Proof it's a look it's
a fun b-movie this is what he does when
he does homage just felt like a b-movie
it was everything that he loved about it
he does it perfectly it's just not
particularly my type of movie but it's a
Tarantino it's exactly what you want
from him if that's the movie that makes
him fall in love with Kurt Russell and
him putting him in hateful eight then
fine we needed to make that movie woo
the second round Django Unchained the
number two seed in the tournament versus
the number three seed Reservoir Dogs
wowee-wow-wow Kristian harloff talked to
me my man Reservoir Dogs is again
everything it was so simple it was so
simple but you got so much character out
of it
that we really have scent of his
dialogue and then you get the evolution
of that dialogue and Django Unchained
out of the two of them though Reservoir
he's going dogs the 3-seat over the
two-seed mark ellis you know i'm stuck
in the middle with these two hell no
nicely done is get don't cut my ear off
I'm gonna say kyle is gonna have a tough
decision to make because I'm taking
django unchained why just look I love
everything about Reservoir Dogs I love
when a new director makes an
announcement film like that and it says
I'm on the map and I'm here to stay but
what django unchained did is it was a
more important movie every everything
that Tarantino was saying with that film
from just making a cool Western into
overtones of slavery and and revenge and
all these other aspects that were going
on to that film I think Django and
chained gets the nod for me bingo bango
bango Mark Ellis is going Django Kyle
Anderson this is incredibly tough
because Reservoir Dogs it's one of the
most you know the classic 90s movies
it's you know one of these early
Sundance movies and everything like that
but I will say that he has gotten better
every time he makes a movie and I think
Django Unchained is is a better movie
it's a longer movie and it's a tougher
movie but it's a I think it's a better
movie all around so that means Django
Unchained is in the finals and we are
about to see what film will join it
there number four seed and glorious
bastards against the number one seed
Pulp Fiction
uh if you're taking Quentin Tarantino is
having two periods his early period
which mirrors making all his crime films
then his later films where he's kind of
making his historical epics
I think you have the top of both I think
I'm gonna go with inglourious basterds
we talked about the first scene I got to
talk about the bar scene he does with
small talk what Hitchcock does with
silence like it's just how do you build
tension with just people bullshitting to
each other it's fantastic so I'm gonna
go with inglourious basterds Wow
I mean I can't fault you for that my
friend I mean I've considered it but I
can't I appreciate it Mark Ellis
you know how Pulp Fiction did so much
for Quentin Tarantino and for movie
lovers in general in the 90s it brought
back the kind of movies that we didn't
know we would ever see again and it
brought back actors we never thought we
would see I'm gonna give Eric Stoltz a
needle and he's going to throw an
adrenalin shot into the heart of
inglorious basterds cuz that's actually
the movie I'm going to take over pulp
fiction and glorious bastards gets
to win over pulp fiction I just think
it's a better movie start to finish it's
a more singular kind of tale and I
enjoyed it more than pulp fiction
I think you're both crazy people I love
look I love inglorious basterds I think
it's a great movie it is it is inferior
to Pulp Fiction the dialogue has never
been better I agree that he has evolved
as a filmmaker throughout since pulp
fiction but the dialogue has never been
better than it is in Pulp Fiction it is
one of the best movies of all time not
just Tarantino it should have won the
tournament and it got knocked out
because you are high and Kaila to know
you wanna say so and so you know he's ha
ha ha ha Christian that was a passionate
defense that was an eloquent defense
that was a defense that may be swayed
some people out there who watched it but
ultimately worthless inglorious basterds
moving on to the finals it is set its
inglorious basterds vs. Django Unchained
the number 4 seed against the number 2
seed
who's it going to be and let's start off
with Kristian harloff Django versus
inglorious Pulp Fiction Django I just
watched recently again to the way that
he uses violence in that movie to prove
a point and the way with everyone from
the the despicable Leonardo DiCaprio to
the protagonist himself in Django it is
such a great well put together movie and
then you have inglorious basterds which
I just argued against pretty strongly
with Pulp Fiction is a movie that you
wish that's the way history went down
you really because of the way he
portrayed that and what Brad Brad Pitt
did with the scalp under the Nazis and
everything there the inglorious bastards
bastards
while Tarantino made an goriias bastards
with his heart and he really cared about
that source material I think as a
filmmaker Django Unchained is a little
bit more of a success even though he
might have felt personally a little bit
more towards inglorious basterds Django
Unchained is the better film
wowee-wow-wow we are all tied up 1-1 and
this entire tournament comes down to
Kyle Anderson critic at large Nerdist
what do you think well it's obviously
it's a tough it's a tough match all of
these
tough matches don't tell us what we
already know right uh the last line of
inglourious basterds I think this just
might be my masterpiece
I think that sums it up I think that
movie is at this moment in his career as
much as I enjoy all of his other movies
I kind of think this is might be his
masterpiece shooting Hitler in the face
deserves the top spot of anything there
you have it
write it down put it in ink spread the
word retweet this repost it inglorious
basterds the greatest Quentin Tarantino
film of all time fellas how do you feel
well look I mean we went through a lot
together boys but I think we can agree
as a unit that inglorious basterds and
Django Unchained are better than Pulp
Fiction very much of morals falsely
false what did you think of this
tournament who do you think should have
won with pulp fiction Rob are you a
death proof guy let us know in the
comments below and I got to thank this
awesome panel you guys this was super
fun and thank you for making the tough
choice absolutely Kyle Anderson with the
Nerdist Mark Ellis see him performing
stand-up comedy all over the country
Kristian harloff Fandango Collider Jedi
Council check him out schmoes No thank
you for watching I'm how Rudnick hit me
up on Twitter
bye-bye won't ask about one other
animated movie the Angry Birds movie
this is a movie that feels three years
too late yeah I crave it well it just
feels like an obvious business ploy yeah
it is the most pop but does anyone play
Angry Birds anymore you still play Angry
Birds let us know in the comments below